después de más de un año de ocupar
campamentos a las afueras de nueva delhi
estos agricultores finalmente celebran
la victoria este lunes el parlamento de
india derogó las leyes sobre la reforma
agrícola que provocaron protestas
masivas a
los que están a favor digan si los que
están en contra digan no
creo que la decisión está con los que
están a favor
de las tres leyes introducidas en
septiembre del año pasado tenían como
objetivo desde regularizar los precios
del sector agrícola y los productores
dicen que habrían destruido la
estructura de apoyo que les garantiza un
ingreso mínimo dejándolos vulnerables
ante las grandes empresas si bien la
derogación se ve como una victoria para
los agricultores dicen que seguirán
protestando hasta que logren otras
demandas entre ellas una ley para fijar
los precios oficiales de cultivos
distintos al arroz y el trigo los
sindicatos entre tanto piden una
indemnización para las familias de unos
750 agricultores que dicen que perdieron
la vida durante las protestas
el seguido este día representa el
martirio de aquellos hombres que
perdieron la vida en las calles durante
el movimiento es también el éxito del
arduo trabajo de aquellos ancianos niños
y mujeres que se quedaron en las
carreteras a temperaturas de 2 grados
celsius
después de defender enérgicamente las
leyes el primer ministro narendra modi
prometió el pasado 19 de noviembre
eliminar la controvertida legislación
una decisión que precede a las
elecciones del próximo año en estados
clave como uttar pradesh y punjab ambos
importantes productores agrícolas